I want to bring up we brought my dogs
came up twice can I just say yeah you
actually dropped my dog your dog while
you were taking a picture for your first
CD thought it would be funny to pick up
a dog and take a picture with the dog
from my perspective I just want to say
that watching Pete hold the dog is like
like I have a three-month-old baby now
and like when you can tell people don't
know how to hold babies and you're just
like holding the dog and they snap a
couple pictures and I'm like 30 feet
away from you and you go um I think I'm
I think I'm done holding them and then
you just went you're six five
that's all in six here you just put him
out in front of you and drunk the French
Bulldog and I still shudder like hearing
the bed to my core you really would okay
three six last week oh good you know
what I think about in that story is that
in that moment I was wrong but you were
cool about it and I would like to say
for the record when I meet your infant
son yes I won't drop him Nicktoons
thanks so much for being here
good other than you know